as annoyed as the fans are about
what we're doing this is bigger than the
fans this is this is really sec a
sacrifice
hey what's up this is terry casagar also
know the silver rings producer for the
wooten
clan concept of the one copy album came
to me two years ago artists needed a
wake-up call
i said why not in order to take a few
steps forward let's take
400 years worth of steps back to the
renaissance age and look at music as a
commissioned commodity from creation to
exhibition to sale
when you look at the ferrari and honda
jazz you accept the fact that the
ferrari is a million dollars you accept
the fact that a honda is twenty thousand
dollars why because it's tangible when
it comes to music it's not tangible it's
digitized to me it's pretty insulting
that
a song
from a great artist like kanye west
jay-z is of equal value to a box of
paper clips
from the dollar shop
that is not a sustainable model
if we were just to like
easily sell it off to a record company
or to a brand or seek an association
it compromises the integrity of the
project and then this whole thing does
become a publicity stunt it becomes a
cheap marketing ploy and that's not what
this is
i can't tell you that
the album features everybody from the wu
tang clan it was produced in the
in the way that
albums were produced between i would say
1993 and 97.
really when wu-tang with the glorious
ring the wu-tang that particular sound
that grittiness
w
will take forever that's going to be
corny